Polls show that most people want to die "quickly, while they sleep, without suffering"
But the chances of this happening to you are very low. So, when the time comes for it
What is the state of death that will be most vulnerable to it?
In 1901 the average life expectancy of people was 31 years, and in nearly 100 years
The rate rose to 71 years. If you live in an advanced country like France or Canada,
They may live up to 82 years, while in developing or minority countries such as
Rwanda has an average age of 64 years.
Many of these people die in strange ways, including the deaths of 27 people in 2015 while taking personal photos (selves).
A man died of heart failure and exhaustion after playing Starcraft for 50 hours,
About 100 people a year die in Russia from the fall of snow-capped blocks. Not to mention death
70 children suffocating by cutting sausages every year.
But if we take the United States as an example of Western countries, we have more than 318 million
Person in 2014, which means the death of more than 2.6 million people. Half of these people often died
Of heart disease and cancer, which is different from the last hundred years, when most people
They die from TB and flu.
The scientific progress of drugs and drugs such as antibiotics and vaccines has reduced the number of deaths
Influenza and tuberculosis, and even reduced rates of cancer death. In 1970, the rate of survival was high
Of the cancer is only 50% - today it has risen to 68% with 15.5 million survivors of cancer
Alive in the United States. Thanks Flag!
Unfortunately, heart disease and cancer are not the causes of sudden death, and are often caused
Death is slow and painful. In fact, 60% of hospital deaths are attributed to one of these cases.
At a rate of 1 per 10 individuals after staying in hospital for a month or more.
Of course, sudden death occurs, with some 13,605 people dying from accidental accidents and injuries
In 2014, in the United States.
Media can influence our fears and worries about dying in strange ways. In the end,
Not one person died of shark attacks in the United States during 2014, but dogs killed 38 people that year.
Many people fear cycling in the city, but you are more likely to die as you walk,
Where about 6,200 pedestrians were killed, while 900 people died while driving the bike.
One person died from a terrorist attack, and 80 died of alcohol abuse
In fact, most terrorist activities in the West are the result of individual attackers
Which does not follow 80% of the Islamic organizations, but either be political extremists,
Or have ethnic or national racial racism, on the world scale in 2015, 78% of deaths from terrorism occur
Only in five countries: Afghanistan, Iraq, Nigeria, Pakistan and Syria.
Your place of living greatly affects the way you will die; in the 34 poorest countries
You are more likely to die because of respiratory problems - not because of smoking, but because of swallowing
Vapors during cooking. Women in Japan are less likely to die from heart disease,
And live to an average age of 87 years, compared to 80 years for American women.
This is often attributed to the Japanese diet.
In the future, is not expected to live for longer ages only, but we may be able to determine the way
And the time of our death. In fact, the latest computer systems have been developed
To estimate the time and the way we might die by 90%, based on medical history,
Lifestyle and other factors. The question is - do you want to know how and when you will die?
Let us know your answer in the comments below.
You can also find the most 5 things people regret before dying in our videos on AsapTHOUGHT.
The link of that video is in the description.
Join our channel to get our science videos weekly! Translation: team translate. Twitter: @autrjim